hi everyone i am mateo kolina
and today i'm going to talk to you about
fastify you know fastify is a project
that i started a few years back
with with thomas and
it has been one of the most uh amazing
uh you know journey of my life to be
honest so i hope you would like
this uh this intro and you would you
know
give it a shot and try it out in your
next project so
let's start um first of all uh uh take a
moment to follow me on twitter at
matocolina i tweet about a lot of things
so hey um only mainly javascript
so i also work for a company called near
form so
if you are interested please check us
out we are a professional services
company based
in ireland but working worldwide to
uh that can help you in any sort of
problems anyway
let's get started on uh on fastify and
why it matters
so uh pestify is
you can find everything for uh rated to
falsify on www.fastify.org it's our main
uh it's our main domain you can find all
the docs there
it's pretty good and it's uh
you know it should be a lot of docs as
usual
everything can be improved so please
please please uh check it out and if you
see something that it does not
um you know that you don't find uh
clear please open an issue and maybe
send out a pr to
improve it anyway uh
and this is actually a good segue for
the very first important part of this
talk
which is you know a genetic principle
that is based uh that underpins
all of opengl's project but
you know specifically fastify an open
source project
is as good as this community is this
it's
extremely important so um in fact
festival we believe
that you know building and maintaining a
web framework for node.js is too much of
a work for a single individual
or even a single company to some extent
and
we you know we encourage everybody
everybody that is using fastify that is
finding
values fastify to contribute back
uh also first if i was born when i met
thomas
and i tried to convince him to to help
me to convince somebody helping in his
journey
and you know i i found thomas and
you know we started working on this
together so it's quite a nice story
i think that i'll talk about it in the
latest in
last year open js so check it out
uh anyway fastified firstify is one of
the fastest
web framework for node.js and you can
you can just you know require it or
import it does work both ways
and you can call it with a logger or
other options
and then you can declare your routes and
you know i think a weight you can use a
sync away to just return an object it
will convert to a json
very simple um now fastify has been
under massive growth in the last year in
the last few years it has now reached
900
000 downloads per month uh and is
probably on the track to reach
a million downloads per month at the end
of the year so
finger crossed and it has now
it has 15 collaborators working on it
and it has reached version three
and it has a very big ecosystem of 185
plugins
uh we are going to ship v4 soon so we're
going to
to storm with a lot of uh with a lot of
news about it
as i said the core values as fastify are
all about
open collaboration and collaboration
across multiple individuals
we always welcome first-time
contributors so if you're using fastify
there's a very good chance that you are
that we will be asked
a very very simple question would you
like to send up a request
to fix your bug your issue or implement
a new feature
it's always important that you
contribute back in this ecosystem
we don't that's what we do here okay
it's it's too complex to build this
thing alone so
we ask everybody to contribute back we
also seek open government we also
approach uh with an open governance uh
in a
fashion which means that uh we ask if
people objects and if not we are lending
them
typically if there are ties or things
that are
too uh complex or that required that
the community is unsure uh one of the
lead maintainers or creators whatever uh
uh step in and try to uh fix it
okay and or maybe try to break the tie
essentially and provide some guidance
and
this person is uh thomas and myself
uh the the fund as i said the key part
of fastify was
built first if i was a community of two
people before it was before any code was
committed
so uh you know the the fact that it's
uh a meld of different companies
different people
different individuals working together
it's it's a key a fundamental issue part
of
fastify um it's
the problem that we have seen why is
this well the reason is because we have
seen that
especially in other frameworks uh in
other initiatives
that uh it's very hard to
for a single company or person justify
the investment
that is needed to build and maintain
a web framework for node.js and what we
have chosen
is to the route that we have chosen is
to spread this effort across the
companies using it
so um you know the typical request that
i
ask everybody that we ask everybody is
when there is a bug i said would you
like to send a pr
and remember to add unit tests so
fastify is pretty unique in that sense
and we create this culture of cornership
that is a key fundamental part of the
fastify experience
um you can check it out
[Music]
we also have a nice governance document
so please check it out to see how our
community works
uh by the way we just can make we if you
contribute to if you contribute to
fastify it's very likely that you will
get the commitment
so please you know if you do sustainable
sustainable and valuable contributions
uh let's go into tech because you know
still fastify is a web framework right
for node.js so it's it's attack
we need to talk about tech uh the first
principle is about overhead we don't
want to add
additional overhead in production why
that is not
truly possible so it's aspirational and
we want to reduce the overhead
that the web framework have we want to
provide a good developer experience
that's a key fundamental part of it and
it needs to work great
for both small and big projects so it
needs to work for a very simple hello
world
but also should also work well for a
company that is a hundred developers
working on several micro services and
some big dc with the system and so on so
forth
it's not simple to build something to to
design a web framework that can
easily grow under an increasingly amount
of complexity
probably because of this we wanted to be
able to migrate to microservices
and serverless and and back uh it needs
to have a very good
security and more importantly data
validation
uh it has a plug-in system again we
don't believe to scope creep so to avoid
scope creep
we created a plug-in system so if
something could be a plug-in it likely
should
it needs to be testable and we do not
want to monkey patch core
to be honest this was one of the parts
that one of the critical part the note
core so this one a critical part that
led me to create fastify in the first
place because a lot of the other
frameworks
actually had a huge focus on monkey
patching node core
also we want to follow semantic
versioning and long term support
so more or less we ship one new major
version per year
and last but not least uh http 1.1 spec
adherence so we want to follow
what http 1.1 so um one of the
uh very nice bits and one nice thing to
chat about
is how fast is fastify
because it's one of you know it's called
in this way
and it uh i wanted to
clarify that fastify is fast enough
so it does not provide a a significant
slowdown compared to not core in certain
cases actually slightly faster than not
core
because it can avoid certain you know
paths that are not great
it's probably faster than whatever you
are using and at this level it's
you know comparable to you just to use
node core this is critical because we
don't want a significant drop
in throughput and performance so if
there is a significant drop in
throughput and performance
we are you you know you you don't want
your web framework
should not be your main bottleneck right
uh it i'll talk a little bit more about
later on why this is fast
why it's it's it's fast so
fastify is also very much loved by devs
and you know it was part of the latest
uh uh state of js which might not be
representative but it's still a good
number that
you know a few people are loving
fastified
so pretty good right i am pretty
pretty happy about about this result
so uh it's uh it's pretty good
anyway uh fastifies also have another
library called mercurius
that you can use on top it provides uh
support for
graphql on top of it and it's also as
it's as well very fast
as it said one of the key part of uh
of fastify is its plugins and we have
both core plugins and ecosystem plugins
uh what is the difference well and the
difference is that core plugins are
maintained by the fastify organizations
so
we typically guarantee to that they work
on every new major so we typically
update all of them
uh when we do assembler major now
consider that we are releasing
essentially to december major fastify
where probably this is 40 45
uh modules so it's quite a big deal that
typically spans across in a couple of
days
so when that happens it's a little bit
of a shift uh in in virgin
major versions anyway um they also tend
to solve the problem in the most
idiomatic way so there's a few examples
like fastifier to load fastify static
and the under pressure module
um the projects in the ecosystem are
maintained by members of the community
for example i wrote some of them that
are very opinionated and things that i
would not want
to include in in in the org so
um it's uh you know there are plenty so
hey
and we have a few we have 141 of those
so you can just write one to be honest
there is a
good guide on the website so what is the
target architecture of a fastify
application
well historically you have we have been
deploying ojs
in a with mvc pattern nvc however as a
as a signal as a significant problem uh
you know once the complexity of
application grows over time
you are either moving you're either
putting the complexity in in
in the models the views or the
controllers
so that's quite of a big a quite of a
big
uh problem for me at least because you
know
it's it's very hard to uh to scale
so uh how can we improve this well um
oh yay here we go so um
how can we uh how can we improve this
well what we can do
is uh we can
you know start structuring our
application instead of using
the mvc concept using just horizontal
uh modules that are you know aligned
with the features of your app
so instead of having like these big
three boxes where you need to fit
everything
you can have just a few independent
modules
as many as the domain of your
application are
and this system actually scale very
way better in complexity because the
moment you start doing this
you can you know you can have
you have segregated the complexity into
and tracking the pieces that you need to
reuse in some other module etc so you
you can now track what is
the interrelationship between the things
in fact it's also the stepping stone for
moving to a micro service
into a micro service architecture micro
services are actually a fundamental part
of how we develop system as well as
lambdas
and so on but the key part is that with
fastify you could
essentially move from a monolith to a
microservice board very easily
because it's all built on the console of
plugins so you will see that in a moment
but it's like super easy
so uh
so let's go a little bit in depth so
fastify is built on uh on various levels
so at the at the bottom of it we have
two libraries avio which is
the loader of fastify and provide also
provide the plug-in system
and pino which is the fastest logger for
node.js
i'm not going to talk about pino so you
know go google it up pinot logger
node.js or something there's a lot of
talks
one of my favorite one is the cost of
login it has been around for a while
it has now reached version six and it's
going to have version 7 we're talking a
little bit
about it later maybe anyway the avio
which is
the the loader it's what you know load
the plugin system
and it provides the extensibility that
is needed
uh by by your app
a vo guarantees to have the plugin
system the hook system
and the decorators so it's essentially
provide the basics in which all these
other features are built upon
on top of that we have like the router
which is find my way uh ajv which is the
validation validator and fast jason
singify which is the
serializer we'll talk about those in a
second
um so the plug-in system this is a key
part of fastify
with the plug-in system you have an
entry point at the top at the very top
and it's uh then the entry point can you
know load plugins
and plugins can load other plugins
re-enter in a
re-entrant way now each one of those
plugins
creates an encapsulation context so
essentially whatever they do you want to
influence it it won't influence
like sibling plugins early descendants
this is critical because then we can say
for example we can pack an app and reuse
it we'll see how to do that
um in fact when if i want to expose a
functionality from one plugin to the
other i can use the concept of
decoration
so i can decorate the request response
or the server to expose some
things to the my the schenden plugins
now this is really nice because you know
it's a
a simple way of providing dependence
injection
or i don't know inversion of control if
you want to call it whatever
so it's actually pretty nice
sorry uh you can also break the
encounter encapsulation
if you want because you can use an
utility called fastify plugin
so that you can actually may uh expose
uh the declaration to your parent as
well as the ending and your siblings
this allows us to build i don't know
reusable modules
so we can use this utility to build
reusable models
the request lifecycle of fastify is
different
than the one of express for example with
the other stuff with other express or
koa you have middlewares that are run
everywhere
with fastify you have a predefined life
cycle
that clearly defines that you can
clearly use to specify when things are
run and this is key because in this way
we can actually
you know avoid monkey patching node core
so
um we have all sort of hooks so
typically the most important ones are
the request hook that's the first one
that is executed
we have pre-handler which is executed
before the user handler
and then we and we have onsend which is
executed
before uh sending the actual response
out
we also provide a recommended project
structure which provide an app.js file
that contains your app
a plugins folder for reusable behavior a
routes folder
for all your routes with a nested
pattern we'll see how to do that and
then a test folder with your
um fast if i provide this concept of
encapsulation as we have seen
now with fastify you've seen the target
architecture
on the left and you know it's uh um
let me actually put it let me actually
put it big here you go
uh so it's uh with fastify
you have you can see that you have your
target architecture on the
on the left and this architecture
provides you you know you tells you to
structure your systems in modules now
you can actually part this to fastify
very easily
because you can have you know your major
application that is composed
your major app that is composed of three
sub-apps or four or five or how many you
want
which have their own plugins and
dependencies and everything so it's
completely they are completely separated
between themselves
it's pretty neat um so
uh on because of all this stuff you can
also use fastify to fully embed an
express app
so you know it's pretty good as i said
logging it's uh one of the
key part of fastify and you can just use
pinot so it's probably the fastest
logger for furnitures
so take a look at the uh take a look at
pino uh
it is great so it's we're virtually on
version seven
how do you use it well you just call
logger dot info pretty neat as
everything you would
you will use in the past um some more
important bits
uh fast if i provide out-of-the-box
cellularization
so it allows you to specify the type the
schema of the object going out
this is pretty important because then we
can create a faster than json.stringify
method function
that you know can give you a nice speed
bump
uh we also written this utility called
fluent.json schema to help you writing
json schema in a nicer syntax
i like it a lot i never use this schema
by the way
we also use ajv which is
uh um and by the way this is the plugin
system syntax so you need to export a
function with
app and ops and ajv is
a the one of the fastest validator for
node.js
so uh it's pretty great also for
embedding so that's why we use it
and hey it's also another openjs
project so
uh testing uh fastify embed an inject
method for fast testing it's really fast
even this matter
and uh in fact that method is so fast
that it at the basis of
the integration for aws lambda so you
can
with this utility at ws lambda fastify
you can just create a very simple proxy
for your
uh fastify app which is essentially just
the app as you would normally use and it
just works
it's pretty neat and it's really fast
like this is actually way better than
embedding an express app inside london
so you can check it out
uh you can use the close method for a
graceful shutdown in normal node app in
case you want to do that
uh okay um so i just want to thank you
for your time
before we go into the uh
we do a little bit of our live coding
example and see how it is
so i'm going to switch to my um
to my terminal that you can all see
so um you know we can start developing
things on fastify so we can do e
app.js and we can do
import fastify from
fastify and what we do is that we do
cast
app we do fastify
hey and then we do app.listen
3000 here we go and
you know because i am fancy i'm going to
bring away here to demonstrate
top level weight of node.js so we now do
we can do
node app and then i can curl it
and we are calling it and you see
it's just not found um so hey not super
nice right
but we can add it out
and we add a route and uh
function wreck i don't need anything
here
so i'm just doing return hello
world
running my app as you see now it's
returning a lowered
cool oh i can also see that there are
all the http headers that i would expect
and they are all there
okay so pretty nice
okay um
[Music]
what do we do next well this app is not
really really reusable
so what we want to do is uh
we want to make uh well this
is refresh okay
let's let's do this okay so we want to
create a
another server another file called
server.js
now i want to split my app because for
example i want to build them and they're
using for
for unit tests so what i do in app is
that i do export a default
a sync function
and i typically do this
and do return app
then i move this into server
and here i do import build from
doctor yes and then i do const app
await build
okay so let's see if the node app does
nothing now
so if i do not server instead and then i
curl
it's still working as as expected cool
okay
pretty neat um so this is actually
pretty nice
um i can also use for example pass in
some opts here
and you know include them here
and then in server i can say for example
logger true so
i can do node server
and then i can curl oh
i didn't do something here so bill
uh did i say this
i probably didn't okay so now you see
it's printed something and we see some
stuff being printed out
this is new like the limited json if i
am
in if i want a some
nicer output for development i can use
pinopretty and as you can see
i can see the request coming in and the
request
that is completed out and we can see
some
usual things about response time and so
on and so forth so here we go
pretty neat uh cool okay so this is
uh some some good example however this
is not really scalable as we saw so
we can use the routes we can create a
routes folder
and in routes i can uh
create a load.js in a load.js
what i am doing is that i'm going to
copy this
and here i'm doing to export default
uh async function
app opts and
and then i'm going to pass this in and
then in my app.js i am just going to
app dot register oh
i need a tiny utility because otherwise
it won't work on windows
so this is for dealing with the sm
so it's called dsm and i'm just going to
do
join um import
well i want to import join import meta
url
recurring file well i can
i don't need this right now so i can
just do
routes and hello dot js
okay then i cancel this and see if it
works
okay so it it did load
and then it's still working cool okay
so now uh one of the things that i want
to use is instead i don't want to load
all the files manually
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
use uh autoload the autoload module
so uh called fastify autoload
and i'm going to use this with this
utility called dsm
and the reason for this it's because
unfortunately uh uh you know in esm you
don't have understand the score the name
or the standard code filename so you
need
a little bit uh you need to work with
file urls and that's a bit convoluted so
i don't really i make mistakes all the
time especially stuff that doesn't work
on windows
so uh i i tend to prefer to use my
utility that has this thing
done so you do you specify your
directory and then you say
import meta url which is the current
file
and you put and then you say
routes so you basically you tell load
everything that
is defined into that folder so you
then now run this and
then i can curl it as you can see it
still works as expected as before
pretty pretty nice uh pretty pretty nice
indeed um cool folks oh one of the
nicest things that
i can actually create a folder nested
structure so i can say
a nested and then say
route.js and then i can
copy this and put it in here
and says hello nested note that i still
use slash here to define this that the
pattern is defined in the
in the in the folder um and
so let's see if if i can launch this
stuff
so this is still working okay cool and
then if i do slash nested
it's still it goes into the nested
folder
um so yeah i just wanted to say
to conclude to conclude this by uh
by saying thank you and uh if you have
any question please reach out to me
at motocolina on twitter or via email
there is also an
ad fastified.js account so
um thank you uh thank you very much
and bye bye